when the Incredibles hit theaters in
2004 it was obvious that it was destined
to become a classic the clever spin on a
superhero family was a massive critical
success that earned two Academy Awards
and raked in well over half a billion
dollars of the box office
you can chalk that up to a thrilling
storyline fantastic animation and great
performances but it also had a lot to do
with the fact that The Incredibles
is one of the smartest and most layered
takes on superheroes to ever hit the
screen if you haven't watched it since
you were a kid here are a few things
you'll only notice as an adult the jokes
for the grown-ups like a lot of films
directed primarily at kids Pixar movies
usually contain a little bit of humor
for the parents in the audience
sometimes it's the kind of obvious gag
that might lead to having the talk a
little earlier than they expected and of
course there are the scenes of a very
happy Helen Parr pulling your husband
back to bed others come so fast if you
blink you might miss them in the early
montage about how supers have fallen
from grace for example one newspaper
headline shows that a hero with x-ray
vision was using his powers to become a
high-tech peeping tom
no wonder they got rid of all those
super creeps the unsung genius Edna mode
The Incredibles resident fashionista and
costume designer is a huge part of the
film but her costumes aren't the only
super tech that's used by the heroes in
just the first few minutes mr.
incredible demonstrates his car's
tricked-out GPS system Auto Drive
function and its ability to transform
into a much speedier vehicle upon
request and that's just one car
the thing is they never once mentioned
the person who created it all giving the
Incredibles universe its most mysterious
unsung hero how did they get so many
wonderful toys that the rest of the
world doesn't have access to and what
happened to them after the supers went
underground syndrome has the tech but he
doesn't seem like the type to share and
no offense but there's no way that Bob
built his own flying car somebody out
there deserves a little more recognition
Edna's voice with their snappy dialogue
and pitch perfect delivery it's not
surprising that Edna mode was The
Incredibles breakout character nut cakes
the surprise only comes later when you
find out that the actor behind the
diminutive fashionista was none other
than writer director Brad Bird
Bird recorded the character's vocals
while making temporary voice tracks for
the
film and even approached actresses like
Lily Tomlin about the part however he
said that the other employees at Pixar
liked his vocals enough that eventually
they stuck Brad isn't the only unlikely
voice actor to wind up in the film
though khari
the Parrs babysitter is played by
animator Brett Parker production
designer Lou Romano lent his voice to -
his teacher and bird son Nick voice the
PAR shocked neighbor Elastigirl is
definitely a feminist if we're all being
honest the real hero of The Incredibles
is Elastigirl
she's a good mother a supportive wife
and the half of her marriage that
doesn't get duped into a secret super
villain plot her iconic introduction
tells us exactly why leave the saving
the world to the men how big so Holly
Hunter who voices Elastigirl has
credited the characters outspoken
persona - writer director Brad Bird
calling him a true feminist in a recent
interview and that shows up in the film
she's not afraid to step back into
action when she's needed standing up as
a strong feminist role model Carrie
deserves a raise most kids watching The
Incredibles for the first time are
probably a bit too young to have taken
on their first babysitting job but once
you have it's easy to see the whole
thing as a horror story starring Carrie
the bars poor put-upon babysitter the
fidgety teen is asked to go well above
and beyond the call of duty in her time
taking care of the young Jack Jack after
the pars left him behind on their
mission to save the world
we've looked and they've never actually
covered spontaneous combustion in any of
the baby-sitters Club books Carrie may
get a bit of a bad rap for giving jack
jack up - syndrome when he finally
relieves her after a stressful night but
for five bucks an hour
you'd probably hand that kid off to an
adult - at the end of the day Carrie
tried her best and she deserves to be
fully compensated for it and get a great
letter of recommendation from Bob and
Helen as well it skewers superhero
tropes while The Incredibles have only
ever been featured in the one big story
that we see on the screen they feel
familiar - and not just because they
argue like real families on road trips
we mister you asked me how to get there
and I told you exit attract federal
trick me downtown
he's coming up they also have a lot of
similarities to some very famous
superheroes particularly the Fantastic
Four mr. incredible obviously echoes the
ffs mr. fantastic in name at least
and a quartet featuring a big strong guy
stretchy hero and an invisible girl with
force fields might seem pretty familiar
to Marvel fans - even though - is the
odd one out in that comparison his
SuperSpeed and red costume are
consciously reminiscent of the flash
it's not just the major characters
either the quick snippets of other
superheroes shown in the film also seem
inspired by the classics including throw
zones ice powers and gazer beams cyclop
esque laser eyes of course while it's
obvious that the creators of The
Incredibles love the superhero genre
they're not above poking fun and it's
more ludicrous extremes either all those
lines about villainous monologuing are a
pretty clear shot at old-school
comic-book dialogue
hey dog you got me monologuing even more
important to Edna moats entire existence
is based around one of the biggest plot
holes in the history of comics the
stylus was born after Brad Bird started
to wonder how every superhero suddenly
became an expert with the needle and
thread after getting the powers and
realized that somebody else had to be
designing these flamboyant costumes
you're the best of the best
I know darling thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you love to